terror group is it possible to a
rational I've asked you two questions
should a mass stay in power and are they
a terror group you're refusing to answer
either of them that is very telling talk
TV is the only place where you get the
truth you've done a book on poetry
poetry and music for the many I love
poetry we can agree on
that on TV on radio and on your
smartphone this is talk
[Music]
TV t p Mor s how far can Israel go
before its defense becomes the very
terrorism it says it's fighting
professors Alan dtz and noral fenin have
bitterly opposing different views in
fact they refused to debate live on
television for 20 years but tonight they
go back head tohe
head Harry and Megan are named The
Losers of the Year by Hollywood's Bible
The Hollywood Reporter as Netflix
reveals their won documentary was a
ratings flop have the sussexes lost
their
Sparkle and Gary lers in hot water again
a new BBC chairman says he's breached
guidelines by taking pot shots of
politicians on X does anyone really care
what jugs
[Music]
tweets live from the news building in
London this is Piers Morgan uncensored
good evening London welcome to Pi Morgan
uncensored it's not every day I find
myself agreeing wholeheartedly with
President Biden but his latest remarks
on Israel are blisteringly accurate and
they could Mark a major Tipping Point in
this war Biden accuses Israel of bombing
Gaza indiscriminately which is of course
a breach of international law and
therefore a war crime he say it's now
beginning to lose international support
he's right but last night the UN General
Assembly voted for a ceasefire 15 53
countries back the motion
153 in
favor 10
against 23
abstentions well that vote was
nonbinding and the UN has been no friend
to Israel but it's clear the winds are
changing fast the grief and fury that
followed October the 7th is now pouring
in the opposite direction as more
stories and scenes of abject misery
emerg daily from Gaza prime minister
netanyahu's compared this to the second
world war to the atomic bomb and the
carbet bombing of places like Dresden in
Germany inflicting massive civilian
casualties to defeat the Nazis but as
President Biden reminded him we created
Global institutions and international
laws after World War to to make sure
that kind of thing didn't happen again
Israel is dependent on the United States
not just for military muscle but for
diplomatic cover the US fights Israel's
corner at the UN it builds alliances
around the world for Israel's right to
defend itself self and to exist history
shows us that when the White House says
stop Israel's guns usually fall silent
and the window of legitimacy for this
war is closing it cannot simply carry on
pounding Gaza to Rubble without proving
it has a plan and a purpose and a moral
Clarity most people might agree that
Hamas after what they did should be
eradicated and that Israel has both a
right and a duty to its people to defend
itself I certainly do but more than two
months into his gruel war with many
thousands of innocent children already
killed is that still what Israel is
doing last what we debated whether an
islamist British GP with extreme views
should remain in his job but during that
debate I was asked a pertinent question
do you consider it as terrorist I I do
not consider Israel to be a terrorist
organization the definition of terrorism
is the deliberate targeting of innocent
civilians that is what Hamas specializes
in that is what Hamas did happening in
Gaza also is what Israel is is what
Israel is doing terrorism no for the
following reason they target terrorists
like Hamas and there are civilian
casualties yes there are but it is not
the aim of the IDF any more than it is
of the British or American AR armies to
Target
civilians I've agreed up till now
broadly with that distinction the
difference between Hamas and the IDF is
clearly
intent but the longer this goes on the
blurrier that line becomes at what point
does Israel's campaign become the very
terrorism it's fighting already the
appalling violence of Israeli settlers
against Palestinians in the West Bank
has been called a policy of Terror by
France specifically designed to displace
Palestinian people and with the Gaza
stripping ruins where are Gaza supposed
to go when this war is finally over
where is the evidence that Hamas is
being eradicated many thousands of
people have been killed we don't know
how many of those are actually Hamas
terrorists what we do know is they're
still in charge Hamas is still
negotiating the release of hostages
still has a chain of command it's still
in control Prim Minister netanyahu's
government is stuffed with farri right
hardliners who won't tolerate backing
down and will'll never consider a
two-state solution just tonight Israel's
ambassador to the UK reiterated a
two-state solution is no longer
something Israel is even considering but
the US has sounded a clear warning that
Israel cannot destroy Gaza and its
people with impunity and right now
Israel needs to listen to its
friends well it's been two decades since
my next two guests agreed to debate one
other on live television both noral
finlin and Alan dtz are Jewish for their
perspectives on the Israel Palestine
conflict couldn't be more different and
they both join me now the lawyer and
author of the war against the Jews Alan
dtz and Professor Norman finklestein
well welcome to both of you um I feel a
bit like Kofi and Nan bringing you two
gentlemen back back together uh but I'm
glad that you've both agreed and I hope
we can have a civilized debate we've had
some pretty uh ranker us debate this
week on the program and I want to try
and really have a proper conversation
about where we are on this war and about
this Burning question and I'll start
with you Alan d is about what we're
seeing in Gaza now is to many people uh
now the very terrorism which Israel set
out to destroy what do you say to people
that think
that it is Terrorism it's terrorism by
Hamas taking human Shields putting
children in the way of Israel's
legitimate military concerns Hamas has a
strategy it's called the CNN strategy I
call it the dead baby strategy kill as
many Jews as possible provoke Israel
into doing what every democracy would do
responding then hide your tunnels and
your Fighters and your Rockets behind
civilians knowing that Israel no matter
how hard they try to avoid civilian
casualties and why would Israel ever
want to kill a civilian it's absurd it
hurts them tremendously but every time
Israel kills a civilian the world
condemns them the United Nations
condemns them and then that process
continues over and over and over again
the people who are being killed today
are being killed as a result of Hamas
actions Hamas started it Hamas uses
human Shields if Hamas lay down its arms
if it surrendered if it uh agreed to
give up control if it uh closed its
tunnels if it stopped its Rockets uh
then no civilians would be killed so
it's a terrible tragedy there's no good
solution there's no perfect solution if
Israel stops now Hamas continues to do
it over and over and over again if
Israel continues it gets condemned and
loses friends abroad and even risks
using the United States it's a terrible
dilemma for Israel all the responsibil
ility all the fault of Hamas for
starting this and let me just end with
one quote on the day after literally the
day after these horrible tragedies with
murders and rapes and robberies this is
what Mr finlin said it warms every fiber
of my soul every fiber of my soul he
called the people who murdered these
innocent Jews me many of them peace
Nicks he called them part of the heroic
resistance and he compared them to the
Jews who were fighting against Nazis in
the Warsaw Ghetto it's that kind of
animosity toward Israel before Israel
fired a single shot which makes it clear
that no matter what Israel does it's
going to be condemned by people like
Norman finlin and by the United Nations
General Assembly I think it was ABI Ean
who once said if the general assembly
were asked to vote on an Algerian
resolution that the Earth is flattened
that Israel flattened it it would win
128 to 32 with 65 extensions and he
would name each of the people so the
United Nations General Assembly Human
Rights Watch Doctors Without Borders
these are not objective assessments
Israel is in a very tough situation and
the future of civilization depends on
Israel being able to destroy Hamas and
avoiding repetition BR let me bring in
professor finstein your response to
that well I won't address the question
of my remark on October 7th because we
already went over that ground in the
previous program and so it would be a
waste of your viewers time if I were to
re revisit that yeah best so let me deal
with the sub yeah thank you so let's
deal with the substantive issue number
one what you seem to be describing as a
new development namely Israel's
indiscriminate assaults in Gaza that's
hardly a new develop with all due
respect to you I I've lost the uh Israel
from is Israel from uh literally day one
set out as its goals so I can quote um
first of all the defense minister there
will be no electricity no food no water
no fuel everything is closed we are
fighting Human animals
and we are acting
accordingly now that was not directed at
Hamas that was directed at the entire
population of Gaza I think your
listeners understand what is the
consequence of denying a civilian
population all water all food all Fuel
and all electricity it doesn't take a
rocket scientists to figure out that
that is a recipe for
genocide number two you quoted or you
had on Douglas Murray who made a
distinction between what he called the
deliberate targeting of civilians versus
the
indiscriminate targeting of
civilians not to want to sound
pedantic but is is's leading Authority
on international law is a fellow named
yuram denstein who I'm sure Alan dtz
knows and Mr denstein or Dr denstein he
stated that there is no fundamental
difference under international law
between the deliberate targeting of
civilians and the indiscriminate Target
targeting of
civilians there is no substantive
difference therefore under international
law according to yuram denstein
Israel is
targeting the civilian population of
Gaza that's another indication from the
get-go not from yesterday not when not
from when it was revealed to President
Biden but from the GetGo Israel has been
engaging in a genocidal war in Gaza now
the genocidal War takes various forms
again I'm going to cite you old quotes
so let's take Gora Island who was the
head of Israel's National Security
Council the equivalent of our CIA and he
said quote
Israel needs to create a humanitarian
crisis in Gaza Gaza will become a place
where no human being can
exist now I'm not here to try to
persuade Mr dtz or Professor dtz I am
here to try to Enlighten your listeners
so I would like them to citate
to meditate over what does it mean to
say Gaza will become a place where no
human beings can exist Mr Island the
former head of the National Security
Council went on to
say severe epidemics in the south of the
Gaza Strip will bring Victory closer and
reduce casualties among IDF
soldiers and then there is Mr
Netanyahu the Prime
Minister not on one
occasion
not from the spur of the moment but
twice in National
addresses in to the nation very
soberly Mr Netanyahu said remember what
AMC did to you this is a war between the
sons of Light and the sons of
Darkness now as Professor dwit surely
knows because he attended Hebrew school
actually he grew up just a few blocks
from me or I should say I grew up a few
blocks from him because he's older he
surely knows that in the midst of a war
in a country
that is schooled in the Bible that when
you say your enemy is
amalec then you are calling for the
destruction the killing of every man
woman and child so with all due regard
to Mr dtz I have to say this issue of
human
shielding is totally beside the point
because it doesn't even come into play
in this particular situation the orders
from the get-go denying food water
electricity and fuel to the entire
civilian
population the order from the GetGo to
turn Gaza into a place that
is not able to sustain human life the
order order from the
GetGo in this battle between the sons of
Light and the sons of Darkness okay I
repeat I do not believe it requires a
rocket scientist to figure out that from
day one which is to say two months you
made Israel has been waging a war of
genocide in Gaza you've made the point
so much you made the point come back to
Professor duritz uh here's the problem
it seems to me I've just listen to
Norman felstein at length uh outlining
that side of the argument it's very hard
when you look at what has actually been
happening in Gaza in the last two weeks
in particular to avoid a conclusion that
Israel doesn't really seem to care if it
levels Gaza to the ground as long as it
can get rid of Hamas my issue with that
is having defended their moral right to
defend themselves as a country is I
don't think they're going to eliminate
Hamas and they're certainly not going to
eliminate the ideology and they're going
to basically end up with a Gaza that's
flattened 2 million people displaced
where are they going to live who's going
to run Gaza how does this actually play
out other than catastrophically
badly it will play out catastrophically
badly because of what Hamas has done we
have to remember first of all you judge
people by their actions not by their
words the quotes from Professor denstein
who's been reti ired for probably 25
years and Elon who's has nothing to do
with the Israeli government are
individuals denstein is 100% wrong I'll
give you an example is there no
difference between Nazis putting Jews
deliberately 6 million of them into gas
Chambers and and other means of death
deliberately targeting them and what the
United States did at Hiroshima Nagasaki
they may both be wrong but there's an
enormous difference between deliberately
targeting civili Ians such as the Nazis
did during the Holocaust and and and
engaging in war actions which you know
are going to inevitably cause death of
civilians so there's an enormous
enormous difference there then he talks
about Amal and Hamas uh I I know the
Bible very well and of course Amal was a
group of people that uh sought to
destroy Israel but when people refer to
amalle they don't refer to the
Palestinian people they refer to Hamas
and Hamas is amalik Hamas is the Nazi
party Hamas are not heroic resistance
people they cut off the breasts of women
and throw them around they behead
children they put children and burn them
to death yes they should be destroyed
it's going to be very difficult this is
not going to have an easy solution
Israel May in the end not be able to
completely uh destroy uh Hamas I hope
they can I hope they can in the way that
the United States and Germany uh
destroyed Nazism and destroyed Imperial
Japanese and in the end what happened is
the Japanese and the Germans were
grateful for it and then the United
States and Great Britain helped rebuild
Germany and Japan and turned them into
great allies that's my hope for Gaza My
Hope for Gaza is that the people of Gaza
will finally be rid of Hamas that uh
took over in a bloody coup and that the
United States and Europe can then
rebuild it better than it was before
like a Marshall Plan uh and hope that a
democratically elected Palestinian
people will then have a two-state
solution I've been
Inu since 1970 let me just jump in there
only tonight the Israeli ambassador to
the UK made it abundantly clear
two-state solution is gone Israel I I'll
play you the clip I'll play you the clip
here yeah but he's wrong is there still
a chance for a two-state solution I
think it's about time for the world to
realize that all
Paradigm failed on the 7th of October
and we need to build a new one and in
order to build a new one does that new
one include the Palestinians living in a
state of their own is that what I think
the biggest question is what type of
Palestinians are in the other side is
what Israel
realized the answer is absolutely no you
see when you hear that this confirms
this confirms but hang on Alan this
confirms what many Palestinians have
feared that for 20 years or more uh the
isi government and Netanyahu in
particular have had absolutely zero
interest in any two-state solution and
and so if that's not let's remember that
but let's remember that Israel offered a
two-state solution 1948
1967 1994 2000 2001 they came very close
2001 2005 2007 the vast majority of
Israeli People Israel is a democracy
unlike Kamas the Israeli people will
vote for a two-state solution if the
circum ances are right if there is no
Hamas and if the Palestinian Authority
will have elections and if the people of
the West Bank and Gaza vote for I'm
going to come I'm going to come back
there will be a two I'm going to come
back to Professor fig in one second but
again today Netanyahu has said
explicitly there can be no Hamas run or
fata run Gaza after this he said it
today he's got no intention of either
Hamas or FASA running Gaza so who he's
going to run it I think going to be not
going he he's not going to be in power
after this after this there will be a
national security government probably
headed by people like Gans maybe Bennett
uh the people of Israel are going to
decide and the people of Israel get to
make that decision and they're going to
decide on a two-state solution the one
thing that's clear is with Gaza
dominated by Hamas there cannot be a two
solution without Hamas anything's
possible okay agree with that I don't
think Hamas can possibly be left in
control I just don't think that this
mission is going to eradicate Hamas in
the time scale which America is not
clearly laying down for their support
Professor finlin you may be right how do
you see this playing out from here okay
I would like to say a couple of things
if you don't mind it's okay yeah number
one uh Professor dtz attaches a lot of
uh importance to the what the people of
Israel
want and so let's look at what the
people of Israel want according to the
most recent polls 60% of Israelis
believe Jewish Israelis 60% of Jewish
Israelis believe that Israel is not
using sufficient force in
Gaza 60% believe that Israel should or
the government should escalate the the
amount of force it should use in Gaza
number two it's the Israeli government
excuse me it's the Israeli people who
democratically elected this Ultra
right-wing government it's not as if the
claims are made that Hamas has been
imposed on the people of Gaza but
there's no imposition in Israel I quite
agree with professor dtz at least for
Jew Israelis for Jewish Israelis it's a
democratic country and they
democratically elected the ultra
right-wing government so I think those
are two very good
indications I can say they're very
officious indications but they are very
good indications of what the Israeli
people
want number three I'm not now going to
go into a long dis position on the
history of the so-called peace process
but I would ask your listeners if they
have the time patience and interest to
just Google what's called the peaceful
settlement of the question of Palestine
and that's a general assembly resolution
that comes up every single year for
decades and it calls for that two State
settlement under June 196 7 border and
it calls for a peaceful settlement on
the basis of international
law now if you look at the voting record
every single year it's the whole world
including the state of Palestine on one
side
supporting a two-state settlement on the
basis of international law and on the
other side opposing it's the United
States Israel and usually some South
Pacific atos like tuvalu Naru and
Micronesia and the Marshall Islands that
record is written in stone it can't be
changed and it makes very clear what is
the obstacle to a settlement the
obstacle is Israel backed by the United
States opposes a two-state settlement on
the basis of international law the law
that has been
defined by the international court of
justice the legal arm of the United
Nations now wrong I'm going to make one
remark now which you will find perhaps
controversial or unacceptable peers
however I hope you'll allow me to say it
and then you can engage it as you said
in a civil
fashion you say that the actions of
Hamas have disqualified it from any
participation in a peaceful settlement
now I am not going to make any brief for
Hamas it's for the people of Palestine
to decide who should be their leaders
who should represent them but I do have
to ask you peers and I respect you so
I'm asking you this as a matter of not
rhetoric but one intelligent person to
another I'm asking a simple question if
it's the case that the actions of Hamas
on October
7th disqualify it from being party to a
peaceful settlement roughly 1,200 people
were killed about 30 30 of them being
children why is it not then also the
case that the actions of the state of
Israel since October 7th the
deliberate the deliberate war of
genocide against the people of Gaza
which has left about
15,000 people dead not
1,200
15,000 and has left dead not 30 children
but has left Dead about 7,000 children
and as we speak now a 7,000 more
children are threatened with death
because of
starvation I ask you as a logical
proposition why isn't the state of
Israel
disqualified from any final settlement
of the question and one last thing
because you ask what do I believe I will
tell you what I believe I believe number
one immediately after the war comes to
an end and the blockade of Gaza that
cruel inhuman blockade of Gaza that war
crime in Gaza that crime against
humanity the blockade of Gaza it has to
be l Ed but once there's a ceasefire and
once that inhuman blockade of Gaza is
lifted once the walls of that
concentration camp come tumbling down
then I see Two Steps step number one
there have to be war crimes prosecutions
I have no problem in saying on both
sides but there must be
accountability you cannot get away with
executing a war of genocide in broad
daylight and then continue and number
two there has to be a settlement on the
basis of international law that is the
only consensus basis for ending the
conflict once and for all okay I want to
just
very quick reply please Professor dou I
was going to end it there but I want to
give you a right of reply on that one
point you're a lawyer uh this point
about international law when President
Biden the head of of America the biggest
strongest Ally for Israel comes out and
says that the bombing has been
indiscriminate he is accusing Israel
directly of committing war crimes that
is a war crime if it has indeed been
indiscriminate is this war now at a
stage where America may pull its support
because they believe that Israel is
breaching international
law it's not uh today 10 Israeli
soldiers including a commander were
killed in Northern Gaza because Israel
refused to bomb that site which it could
easily have done instead it sent in
Brave 18 19 20 year old some of them
considered children under the Hamas
definition of anybody under 19 and they
were all killed because Israel made a
decision not to bond indiscriminately it
is never bombed indiscriminately it has
always bombed part of process say that
it
is because he usually very often use car
carelessly uses words I'm a supporter of
of Joe Biden but he's wrong it's not
indiscriminate it's very very
discriminate in terms of international
law uh uh finklestein is just dead wrong
uh I helped draft 242 the UN resolution
I was working with Arthur Goldberg in
1967 and that talked about territorial
adjustments Israel has the right to make
some territorial adjustments they
shouldn't have had occupation of uh
civilians but going back to the 67
borders is an invitation to suicide and
you know when the blockade of Gaza will
end the day that Hamas is no longer in
control okay and the day when Rockets no
longer attack Israeli civilians that's
the day the blockade will end the
blockade is a good thing designed to
prevent Hamas from firing Rockets using
tunnels and doing a repetition of what
happened on October okay I do I do not
agree that the blockade is a good thing
I do think that the occupation of Gaza
for many decades has been uh a terrible
thing the plot of the Palestinians has
been horrific none of that justifies
October the 7th which is uh one of the
worst Terror attacks of modern times but
I'm grateful to both of you for agreen
to come together and having a civilized
debate about this we got to do more
talking this will only get resolved In
The End by people talking and reaching a
resolution so thank you both of you very
much indeed civiliz by thank you I
appreciate it thank you well on says the
next uh definitely a gear change who
grants L's role is as an OA lumper in a
movie called Wonka now he's depriving
actors of short stature dwarves their
chance at a major role but now he's
complaining about it is Hugh Grant as
I've long suspected the biggest Wonker
in Hollywood where Dylan posle returns
to the show
next we're here thanks for joining us
you with talk TV on TV on radio online
on your smart speaker as well criminals
to using XL Bully dogs as weapons to
threaten others no matter how well
trained most dog owners will tell you a
dog can turn you know what I love about
to today we do it all tunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming around the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the other
the police are pro Palestine that is
just not right you swearing off in the
police to act without fear or favor the
co inquiry seems to have turned into a
sort of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it know whether it's a FSE
or a
tragedy the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million 140
million pound so far so40 million pound
so far results nil absolutely nil are we
only going to be trusting sources like
meta and Google where is our unbiased
news going to come from Kell in winter
is
cold that is here from the Jeremy Corbin
B Kevin O Sullivan is the worst
presenter on talk TV sitting on his fat
ass for AIT if you're walking towards me
and you're a vegan she have a great big
orange sticker over here saying watch
out vegan's
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walks into a
branch of McDonald MK mous man M mous
man M he should be easy enough to catch
this guy shouldn't he I mean he's got
house full of
mice
this is a major Summit President Biden
decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz
film sunak and the current conservative
government are not conservative why
don't you leave that party and come to
one that actually shares your ideology
this has been a party political
broadcast on behalf of the reform UK
party kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solve this is
really unfair what what what's unfair if
it's on camera we're not doing
interviews yes I'm going to do you're
going to Res yes cuz I cannot continue
my work when I say I am God I'm not
joking did you feel Elvis was
controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your questions are
you prepared to call h a terror group is
it possible to have a rational I've
asked you two questions should Hass stay
in power and are they terror group
you're refusing to answer either of them
that is very telling talk TV is the only
place where you get the truth you've
done a book on poetry poetry and music
for the many I love poetry we can agree
on
[Music]
that welcome back we like to stand up
for the little guys on the show and
today that means literally standing up
for little guys against Hugh Grant first
he took the sole role
as an Umpa lumper in the new Wonka movie
depriving dwarf actors of their chance
at a coveted role and he has had the
audacity to whine about it moaning about
everything about the facial cameras used
by animators it's like a crown of thorns
he wailed very uncomfortable I made a
big fuss about it I couldn't have hated
the whole thing more I slightly hate
making films but I lots of children and
need money meanwhile he said he's too
old and fat and ugly to Star romantic
comedies which is actually the first
time he and I have ever agreed about
anything he's ever said but returning to
the show now is Dylan posle is also
known by his wrestling ring name horns
Dylan great to have you back on
uncensored I thought about you
immediately I saw Hugh Grant moaning
about the role that he played as an Umpa
lumper because not only did he take a
role that should have been for an actor
like you but he then complained about it
what was your
reaction I don't I I fully don't
understand why he's complaining about it
he knew what he was getting into when he
accepted the role he he he obviously
knew so if there was any thought in his
mind that there would be uh backlash or
whatnot um even himself feeling that way
why take the role in the first place
whether it's the production crew uh
asking him to do the role he should have
then if there was any question of it
should have not accepted the role right
now the president of little people of
America Mark panelli said the most
troubling aspect of the Hugh Grant
situation is that from what I can tell
they have CG have the physical
attributes of a person with dwarfism
like the larger arms or shorter hands so
he looks like a person with
acondroplasia just like the Umpa lumpas
from the film of the early 70s they're
trying to maintain the physicality of
dwarfism but erase the authenticity of
drism which is troubling and that's why
you go well this is like a physical
version of blackface would you agree
with
that I I wouldn't go that
far um I have a condr plagia myself I
have a condra plasia myself uh this is
kind of going back to the the CGI or the
uh normal siiz actors in The Seven
Dwarves roles where it's taking roles
from um the dwarf Community from my my
community and giving them to average
size actors when those roles for my
community are very few and far between
so when roles like the Oompa Loompa or
the Seven Dwarves are really key roles
for people like me it's a it's really uh
a kick in the guts and and it's a it's a
it's a hard pill to swallow it really is
and of course it comes to then I'm sorry
I was gonna say it's very hypocritical
for because we've seen time and again
Hollywood stars standing up and saying
only gay uh actors can play gay roles
only disabled actors can play disabled
roles uh only trans actors can play
trans roles and so on it seems like
you're the only group who do not have
Hollywood's protection in that
regard that's a yeah I I just don't
understand
um especially now you're you're you're
spending the extra money on CGI and on
edits and all of that when there are
actors such as myself um and other
dwarves out there that would have loved
this role I'm sure um I would have loved
it obviously uh I'm I'm trying to do
more acting and more more roles whether
it be dwarf roles or normal size roles
so for me it would have been an absolute
dream role um it's it's all in in
nowadays how it's viewed and I
understand completely how the Oompa
loomas maybe have been viewed in current
day compared to in the past but it's
just I I I these are roles that were
made for people like me what is your
message to hug said he couldn't have
hated the whole thing more he said asked
if if you lik the final product not
really was it fun should have been it
wasn't I hate making films I just have
lots of kids and need the money he has
got lots of kids by lots of women
probably does need the money but just it
just struck me as being just so
dismissively cheap of him to do that
knowing the backdrop of the
controversy he knew what he was getting
into when he took the role that's that's
my whole thing he knew the character he
knew how it would be viewed edited and
all that but he still took it um that's
where I don't really obviously I have I
have zero sympathy for him uh feeling
this way and it's even more than that I
just I feel it's a it's it's it's a
shame that he did take that role because
it could have went to some someone in my
in uh in my of my stature well not only
somebody more appropriate frankly but
also somebody who would have probably
loved the role and celebrated the role
and talked about your joy at playing
that role in a movie of this
size it's an absolutely huge movie and
an absolutely huge part of the Wonka
story and backstory um how how they're
per you know perceiving it so for it to
go to a person in the DF Community would
have been absolutely enormous so are we
agreed then Dylan that he is Hollywood's
biggest
Wonker I
mean I I don't know about that I know
that I would have loved that role uh so
I would like I say I'll spare your
normal size roles yeah I'm going to call
him out I'm calling him a Hollywood
Wonker a gigantic statue a massive siiz
Wonka uh Dylan great to have you back on
the show thank you very much much thank
you very much on say the next talking of
wonkers finally Crown the Harry and
Megan deserve they've been named this
year's biggest losers this will really
hurt by the Hollywood report Hollywood
Reporter which is the show biz Bible for
Hollywood I'll talk to Tommy Len and the
be
[Music]
pack we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on on TV on radio
online R your smart speaker as well do
you know what I love about talk today we
do it all sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming around the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the other
the police are pro Palestine that is
just not right you swearing off in the
police to act with without fear or favor
the co inquiry seems to have turned into
a sort of pantomim there's not really
any substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a tragedy there
needs to be one human per machine to
come and rectify beats and the clanks
and when it goes roll unexpected item in
bagging a know are we only going to be
trusting sources like meta and Google
where is our unbiased news going to come
from Gram was president of the Cambridge
Union which is the rubbish version of
being president of the Oxford Union
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking living if you're walking towards
me and you're a vegan you have a great
big orange sticker over here saying
watch out vegan's about Twitter you sons
of can you please reinstate my account
thank you this is a major Summit
President Biden decided this was
important after watching a Tom Cruz
film kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solve when I say I
am God I'm not joking did you feel Elvis
was controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your question are
you prepared to call h a terror group is
it possible to have a
rational talk TV it's the only place
where you get the
truth this is to
[Music]
TV welcome back to our s Harry and Megan
have been making headlines again this is
the sun's front page today naming them
Hollywood's biggest losers which is what
they were branded in a withering report
in The Hollywood Reporter which is a
very credible Bible of the Hollywood
industry it's also been revealed that
their family trashing Netflix
documentary costing 88 million pounds
didn't even rank in the top 200 most
watched Netflix shows was beaten by both
Paw Patrol and Peppa Pig and it's also
been revealed that their charity archa
which you may remember both of being the
absolute pillar of compassion that's
what its mission statement is when of
course the two people behind it don't
show anybody anything remotely to do
with compassion that their donations
have absolutely collapsed in year two on
year one so all in all not been a good
little period uh for these two uh I'm
joined by the host of out kicks Tommy
Tommy Len and my pack talk to you be
contributor Esther krer the daily M
associat Kevin McGuire before I get to
Megan and Harry Tommy um your reaction
to Hugh Grant playing an Umpa Loompa in
Wonka um we just had an interview with
Dylan Pell you know on behalf of of
dwarf actors just saying not only did he
have the audacity to take their coveted
role from from them but he also has
never stopped whining about it ever
since is he the biggest whiner in
Hollywood you
well there's a lot of whiners in
Hollywood so that would be a hard Crown
to put on anybody's head so many
contenders to discuss but I will say
this Hollywood for a long time is like a
snake eating its own tail they want all
of these diversity Equity inclusion
standards but then they wrap themselves
up in a messy bow because they can't
figure out if they should discriminate
against dwarf actors or they should put
more in or who they're going to upset or
who they're going to anoint one day to
the next that's the problem they decided
that Merit wasn't important anymore and
they decided that trying to appease
everybody and to tipto around political
correctness was the way they were going
to go and now they can't navigate the
waters they've created for themselves so
I don't shed a tear for Hugh Grant I
don't shed a tear for Hollywood in
general certainly not Harry and Megan
they are all products of the same
disease which I refer to as leftism or
liberalism but it can go by many names
wokeism might be another name foris
so many people you and I agree about
everything to do with wokeism quick
reaction to Hugh Grant from you to eser
I mean just spoiled brat isn't he I mean
this is the kind of The Ungrateful sod
section of the show where Harry Megan gr
all fit into the same bubble you know I
feel sorry for him because he's someone
who's I think is a fantastic actor he's
had a very decorated career at this he
plays the same role well yeah but but
the thing is as he says by his only
Mission he's now too old fat and ugly to
play a romantic League yes he's still
getting a role this is the point to to
to then take the role take the money and
then winge about it it's so
disrespectful Kevin I think his finest
role was Jeremy Thorp a British
politician in a BBC series but it does
feel like he's ungrateful and priv he's
taking the money now perhaps he thinks
an um lumper is beneath him maybe he
wanted to be Willie woner himself let to
play the role yeah but he is an actor
you've argued many times I have but I'm
actually throwing back the hypocrisy of
the Hollywood he'll come back to wiad us
about climate change and helping the
poor and supporting La all the things
let's go back to Tommy and talk about
Harry and Megan uh I got to say I did
chuckle when I saw that The Hollywood
Reporter had completely buried them as
the Biggest Losers of the Year
culminating in the South Park takedown
which made them a laughing stop but I
think that the reality is uh America's
just seen through them
right yeah these two suffer from not
only wokeism but narcissism and I would
also say laziness and that's proof in in
the Spotify deal that they had where she
failed to produce really any episode so
that's their problem they think very
highly of themselves they want both
things they want fame and privacy but
they also don't want to work very hard
for anything beyond their Royal titles
which they continually crap on so they
try to have it both ways once again I'll
use the analogy the snake eating its own
tail I do think it's interesting that
Hollywood is turning on these two
because you know when they moved to the
United States they really were put out
on a silver platter like we would be so
happy to have them I will tell you all
you can gladly have them them back we do
not we do not want them back thank you
abely I I think I said to you before
Tommy you Americans you sent two of your
women over to our royal family and it
hasn't gone well first first one led to
the abdication of our king and the
second one has nearly brought down the
monarchy so you lot a banned no more
American women in our royal family uh
you can keep them uh just to repeat what
Holly reporter said after a whiny
Netflix documentary a whiny biography
spare even the titles of y gripe and an
inert podcast the Harry and Megan brand
swelled into a sanctimonious bubble
begging to be popped and South Park was
the pin a glorious assessment of these
two little Wass uh Tommy always great to
have you on the show thank you very much
indeed appreciate it love your show
outkick on outkick so keep that going
being here um we're actually gonna let
Tommy go because I want to come back and
talk with these two about Gary liner Who
Tommy won't know much about uh I'm about
Gary liner who the new BBC chairman
incoming guy reckons he's breached the r
the rules about social media and people
think he should be perhaps fired for
having a popet politicians and a popet
him we'll discuss that after the
[Music]
break we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online on your smart speaker as well
criminals to use EXL bully dogss As
Weapons to threaten others no matter how
well trained most dog owners will tell
you a dog can turn do you know what I
love about talk today we do it all sunak
sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming around the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the other
the police are pro Palestine that is
just not right you swear an off in the
place to act without fear or favor the
co inquiry seems to have turned into a
sort of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a
tragedy the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million £140
million pound so far so 140 million
pounds so far result nil absolutely nil
are we only going to be trusting sources
like meta and Google where is our
unbiased news going to come from Kell in
winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talk if you're walking towards me and
you're a vegan she have a great big
orange sticker over here saying watch
out vegan's
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walks in into a
branch of McDonald MC mous man MC mous
man MC mous he should be easy enough to
catch this guy shouldn't he I mean he's
got house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz
film sunak and the current conservative
government are not conservative why
don't you leave that party and come to
one that actually shares your ideology
this has been a party political
broadcast on behalf of the reform UK
party think all they have to do is take
pictures of everything just shut down
Tik Tok problem solve this is really
unfair what what what's onir if it's on
camera we're not doing interviews yes
I'm going to do you're going to resol
yes cuz I cannot continue my work when I
say I am God I'm not joking did you feel
Elvis was controlling I've been
answering your question you answer mine
it's actually not my job to answer your
questions are you prepared to call h a
terror group is it possible to have a
rational I've asked you two questions
should a m stay in power and are they a
terror group you're refusing to answer
either of them that is very telling talk
TV is the only place we you get the
truth you've done a book on poetry
poetry and music for the many I love
poetry we can agree on
[Music]
that welcome back to
unsensible fact Esther and Kevin are
still with me let talk about Gary ener
so Gary ener good friend of mine full
disclosure um I've never understood why
anyone cares too much about his views on
political stuff he's perfectly entitled
to I watched him a match of the day he
never mentions on that I couldn't
couldn't care less personally um however
interestingly it's been a big furor
because he he was one of a number of
celebrities who signed a petition about
this against the government's Rwanda
plan uh and that apparently is allowed
under the new BBC rules for people who
are not using current affairs presenters
like him but he then got into a bit of a
set to with various Tory MPS one was
Grant shaps who had a poppet him and so
Gary hit bag a tad Rich for someone who
can't even stick to one name four chaps
schnaps quite a good line the other one
was Jonathan gulis um who had said he
breached impartiality rules and he said
Jonathan has read the new guidelines
which say had someone read them to him
so and Sh say he should stick to
football and it's on these two points
that Samy Asar the incoming chairman
said seemed to be breach because it's
attacking individuals to which Kevin I
would say if Tor MPS want to have a pop
at Gary Dena for something he's done
he's perfectly entitled to have a pot
back isn't he I agree no no absolutely
and if he was picking on them and
singling them out that would be totally
different but the BBC is tying itself in
knots he's not doing news and current
affairs he's a sports presenter on Match
of the day when he's presenting the
highlights of the football he's not
going into politics he's not seeing down
the right wing is better than bra the
one time I criticized was at the start
of the catar World Cup when he did this
big H about their human rights I thought
he won't do that when they go to America
right so I didn't like that but
otherwise I just don't have a problem
the thing is even if I agreed with his
politics and what he was saying I I
think the issue is not with him but it's
with the BBC because the BBC have set
this
precedent you can't have someone like
him you know on because the thing is if
you
do pretend to be impartial here's the
issue but the public has to pay for the
BBC and so with that we have certain
standards that we expect I don't care if
I agree with everything that came out of
Gary L's mouth I don't want this person
who's clearly very partisan in his views
representing the some way and he doesn't
need the money he doesn't need the money
I honestly think you just say look news
current affairs you don't tweet about
anything which shows your political
unsustainable it's an unsustainable
stand but the ones who want nothing to
do with it who unsustainable Alan sugar
sir Alan sugar Lord sir Alan sugar uh
presents The Apprentice does it very
well hugely controversial tweets
absolutely all the time all these people
don't need the money but would you say
he should be sacked no I'm not saying he
should be sacked I'm saying why would
they want to keep working for whether
you whether you agree with them or not
it doesn't matter it's their right to
say what what they are guys got to leave
it there I don't think I think it's a
storm in a teup but good to see you both
thank you very much whatever you're up
to keep it un sensed T
[Music]
night
we're here thanks for joining us you're
with talk TV on TV on radio online on
your smart speaker as well they have
made a statement condemning Hamas we
expect to see the crown revisit Harry's
anti-semitic Halloween costume criminals
to using XL Bully dogs as weapons to
threaten others no matter how well Tred
most dog owners will tell you a dog can
turn you know what I love about to today
we do it all sunak sella scun
I rather like David Cameron I don't sort
of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the israelies are very
conciliatory all they want is to be
recognized the timing of this hamus
attack comes because there was the
expectation there was going to be a deal
down to normalizing relations with Saudi
Arabia the Tories love a scrap you can
almost see this coming around the tracks
with sella bravman she's heading up one
side and richy soon at the other
reshuffles usually very dull this one
had booster Rockets attached to it
certainly the tone has shifted in terms
of what rashak has done the question now
is what he does next the police are pro
Palestine that is just not right you
swear an oath in the police to act
without fear or favor the co inquiry
seems to have turned into a sort of
pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a tragedy talk TV
has spoken exclusively to a member of
the Blade Runners do you have a message
for sadique Khan we're not stopping
until you
stop the amount of time it's taken the
number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what do we
saying it's cost about 140 million 140
million so far so40 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from Kell in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin o suan is the worst presenter on
talk TV sitting on his fat ass talking
for a liit if you're walking towards me
and you're a vegan she have a great big
orange sticker over here saying watch
out vegan's
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walks into a
branch of McDonald MC mous man MC mous
man MC man he should be easy enough to
catch this guy should he I mean he's got
house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this is important after
watching a Tom Cruz film did